okay oil too this promotes break and we
men that child it's adobe more who
her questions for a while but donald
rumsfeld reach you simply red language
to read and understand and be able to
sorry for span de absolute tanks degrees
and whatever i believe download samsung
reading chatted be for great sex cry
whatever week in the showroom is 13,000
rode so white shirt of becomes less
important hou belgian able to the bbc
dasn't breed en de washington post en ze
riri disturbing stories about donald
trump is nou refusing to read this
presidential daily briefing switch in
such an important part of the last seven
president daily routine
this is something that each day
service resets wie guyot politico
situation for president of the united
states and cramps da's een reader
period from pin die long
cheat sheet torii to the qdb en  even where war gdb
is happening
how is lola longer frequency we have
for so long and rely on the oral pant
briefing so is a  code and special you
won the race and you're getting the oral
briefing is you like again tensions pen
by everyone in version but don't
forget to de ride a briefing scissors
already planned and down for trump so
one you just great with the washington
post pitch euro
choose to reading okay choose to reading
presidential briefing there he spin
down down the toe want is called
mostly pictures graphs and maps en de
view bullet points and i still not
getting the bad okay and didn't know getting
the oral persian daily ride
source remember  which each god chris
wallace on fox news
here ain't it the gary gary debica ski
is like en smart person or maybe this
one you were getting the presidential
daily notes from your angelique
engadget online idea it's a
historical and scoops if
i provide teaser rate  comes beeping or the
government meter briefing and if you need
insight and change of the sports media
myconian command interest one minutes you need
a real killer
namely a smart press e  n has the
offers rolled cm and so a words and
free single day
for the next year's bright choose leica
smart person and of course i said you
get a gig at the briefing montini z-bar
june de briefing in order de know
whether it's a  notable briefing and the
view analysis with george's care then be
at the washington post key is receiving
the war briefing
white lover lover frequency an average
debriefing she finds the small one in
frequency through all so happening leather and
leather in the game which brings tattoo
possible interpretations what  is is a
disco light go vigilant necklace
intelligence picos
push critical notes bitter anyway and
his life bones playable in counter
services the russians in the oval office
order matthew zero just be generally
glass message dessert argument ben
jeremy presidents we begin the
president gui prefer not get  the
presidential briefing is simple i know
someone who should be president and the
skerry partners
jared kushner is caring the pr  esidential
daily briefing reviewing the
presidential daily briefing she still
looks at carmine security clearance
pitch coach picked up the story i talked
about catching the show
very very scary rod and james woods
king on and off oval office and the
white house